[موسيقى]
ساق حديديه او يد خشبيه معكوفه هكذا صورت
السينما الاطراف الصناعيه البدائيه لكن
التاريخ حمل في جعبته الكثيره حول نشاه
هذه البدائل الوظيفيه بدءا من الحضاره
المصريه حتى عصرنا هذا الذي شهد صناعه
الروبوتات فكيف حدث ذلك
يعود اقدم دليل على استخدام طرف صناعي
ثلاثه الاف عام وكان لاصبع صنع من الخشب
والجلد عثر عليه كجزء من مومياء مصريه
كذلك استخدم الرومان المحاربون الخشبه
والحديد لتصميم ارجل واذرع صناعيه وعرفت
لديهم اقدم الاطراف الصناعيه التي سميت
ساق البامبو في العصور المظلمه اعتمد
الفرسان المدرعون على الاطراف الصناعيه
الحديديه التي صنعت من ذات المعدن الذي
تصنع منه دروعهم واستخدمت انذاك لغرض
اخفاء الطرف المفقود في تلك الفتره كان من
اشهر ما ينسب الى القراصنه الذين يمارسون
الملاحه البحريه المشابك ذات والخشبيه
والايادي المعدنيه التي ظهرت على شكل
خطافات كان طباخ السفينه انذاك هو من يجري
عمليات البتر وان كان ذلك بمعدلات بنجاح
ضعيفه في القرن الخامس عشر الميلادي اصبح
الجراح الفرنسي والحلاق العسكري امبرا
وازباري ابا لبدر الاطراف والاطراف
الصناعيه الحديثه حيث ربطها باحزمه وادوات
تحكم لقفل الركبه كان باري ايضا اول من
ادخل يدا صناعيه مفصليه وساقا بمفصل ركبه
مقفل وهي التقنيات التي لا تزال مستخدمه
حتى اليوم
كذلك قدم زميله صانع الاقفال المسمى لورين
ايضا مساهمه مهمه في مجال الاطراف
الصناعيه باستخدام الجلد والورق والغراء
بدلا من الحديد الثقيل خلال القرنين
السابع عشر والثامنه عشر شهدت صناعه
الاطراف الصناعيه تحسينات متواصله من
ابرزها الطرف الصناعي الذي طوره الجراح
الهولندي في ترفردون بمفاصل متخصصه
اساور جلديه لتحسين الارتباط بالجسم كما
نجح الانجليزي جيمس بوتس في ابتكار طرف
صناعي فوق الركبه في عام
1800 مصنوع من الخشب وقدم المرنه متصله
بمفصل ركبه فولاذي من خلال اوتار هاجر هذا
التصميم الى الولايات المتحده في عام
1839 واستخدم بشكل رئيسي للتعامل مع
المصابين خلال الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه
ففي اربعينيات القرن التاسع عشر ومع ظهور
التخدير الغازي تمكن الاطباء من اجراء
جراحات بتر اطول واكثر دقه ما سمح لهم
بالعمل على جذع الطرف بطريقه اكثر مرونه
شهد القرن التاسع عشر ايضا تطور تقنيه
المفاصل وطرق الربط القائمه على الشفط كان
من اهمها تطوير ذراع صناعيه يمكن التحكم
فيها عن طريق الكتف المعاكس باستخدام
احزمه ربط تشبه الى حد ما طريقه التحكم في
الفرامل على الدراجه
في عام
1945 تم انشاء الاكاديميه الوطنيه للعلوم
التي وجهت اعمالها للاستجابه لتدفق مبتوري
الاطراف المخضرمين في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ولغرض دفع التقدم العلمي في تطوير
الاطراف الصناعيه في السبعينيات من القرن
الماضي طور المخترع الامريكي ايسيدو
امارتينيز الذي عانى من بدر احد اطرافه
طرفا صناعيا سفليا يركز على تحسين الحركه
وتقليل الاحتكاك حيث خفف الضغط وجعل المشي
اكثر راحه مما ادى الى تحسين حياه العديد
من المرضى
خلال السنوات الاخيره بدات الاجهزه
التعويضيه تعتمد اكثر على الحوسبه حيث
ساعدت التطورات في اساليب تصميم الحاسوب
والتقنيات الجراحيه ودخول عصر الروبوتات
في تحسين الاطراف الصناعيه وظيفيا وجماليا
مع تطورات تقنيات التصميم للاطراف
الصناعيه يعيد المستقبل بمزيد من
الابداعات التي قد تجعل حياه الكثيرين
اكثر يسرا